Terry what did director Park teach you
about filmmaking well rather than teach
me something there was a lot of
conversations taking place we met
together we first met while he was still
rewriting his script so a lot of
conversation took place and I felt like
I was going along this process with him
right from the beginning did you know
that you had been chosen among 1500
other young women did you know that
during the audition process I only found
out a little bit I knew that there were
many but as to the exact number I found
only later on at what point did you know
the sexual nature and the nudity in the
film would be part of your role a very
prominent part during the audition
process that Clark showed me a copy of
the script so I found that and I have to
ask were you terrified or was this a
challenge that you wanted to take on a
little bit of both well I had to think
about it paulus hair is quite troubling
at the beginning but after a lot of
contemplation to which I was able to
convince myself that this was what's
required for the character I was able to
from that point on go along with it
without any